dans cet hémicycle de l'ancien conseil
général des spécialistes de la lutte
contre les moustiques venus des quatre
coins de la planète tous ont le même
problème les moustiques deviennent de
plus en plus résistants aux insecticides
alors il faut trouver des solutions
quel que soit des océans indien et
pacifique atlantique
c'est là le rôle de ces chercheurs on
remplacera pas complètement les insectes
ici et on sait que ça ne suffira plus il
ya de moins en moins de produits qui
sont proposés on cherche des méthodes
alternatives basées sur la biologie de
l'espèce notamment en essayant de
l'introduire
des techniques qui capture les
moustiques ou les font fuir ou protège
l'individu voir modifier aussi le
comportement des solutions sont déjà
utilisés dans certains pays d'amérique
centrale ou en australie
les chercheurs modifie génétiquement les
moustiques l'une des solutions les
rendre stérile et aussi d'autres
techniques maintenant qu'ils ont trois
ça s'appelle les wolbachia qui vise à
introduire dans les populations de
moustiques une bactérie qui qui empêche
la réplication du virus dans le
moustique et cette technique ne vise pas
à des fins moustiques mais à propager ce
virus de cette bactérie dont d'un
moustique pour empêcher la transmission
de la dengue à l'homme entre moustiques
et l'homme dangereux pour les hommes ça
c'est à l'étude normalement ce bactérie
n'est présente que celle moustiques un
colloque organisé par la ctm et la rs et
le premier constat c'est que dans la
caraïbe la lutte s'organise en fonction
des rois sanitaires en vigueur dans le
pays
rapport au contexte politique où les
pays de la caraïbe ne sont pas soumis
aux mêmes réglementations que nous elles
peuvent expérimenter des fois beaucoup
plus de choses que ce
la loi française et la réglementation
européenne permettent donc on n'y a pas
vraiment de pays plus avancés que
d'autres ya juste des contextes
différents
d'où justement un enrichissement que
chacun peut avoir notamment au moment de
ce colloque ces chercheurs échangeront
leurs expériences jusqu'à vendredi soir
le 7 décembre
objectif lutter contre à un insecte
présents sur notre terre depuis la
période des dinosaures